but let's define that though let's
define that okay so what what is castro
what is hitler the word that comes to my
mind is force right that's what force is
isn't that the real uh uh
mo of those extremes
so what is the definition of
dictatorship can you pull up tyler the
definition of dictatorship hopefully it
hasn't changed to a sweetheart of a
person who loves their people and
hopefully they've kept the definition uh
uh all right let's see what is the
definition of dictator 40 years of
dictator i want to know the definition
of dictatorship type in dictatorship
it's a former ground character as a
single leader or group of leaders that
hold government power promised to the
people in little or no toleration for
political pluralism or independent media
okay so can you go back to the images
real quick
that you just had
i thought i saw something that
is that george bush and obama as this is
exactly what i'm talking about here is
when you use
such rhetoric yeah for people that are
actually decent you lose your your
argument yeah right you're right so the
moment you drop that word hitler you
lose credibility with me the moment you
drop that word on both sides by the way
yeah it's being totally fine but let me
go back to this whole thing with calling
him the dictator when you think about
the word dictator what word you think
about i i'll give you a couple words i
got you said one of them i said force
you said what you said um i think of
death
but what do you think about when you
think about the word dictator what do
you think about words specific words
control control okay i agree
totalitarian totalitarian so let's say
force and control okay all right so tell
me what is force and control is force
forcing everyone to take the vaccine is
that force mandates
isn't that a form of mandate so if nikki
really
needs to redefine what she means by that
to understand how she went through the
military side seeing like 22 different
states i understand what part she's
going to yeah but florida as much crap
as people talk about florida the nba
playoffs was in florida okay the the
super bowl florida a bunch of ufc bunch
of comedians comedians are moving
forward
yeah i mean if you look at how many
different if florida
sucks as bad as it does why do you keep
doing events in florida why don't you go
to different places why is it that the
number you know what's the number one
city in america for conventions do you
know what's in number one orlando
orlando's number one in america most
people think it's vegas believe it or
not orlando's number one did you know
that or no i got to go to orlando
i'm in orlando two weeks for a
convention orlando's number one
for convention so when you drop names
like words like that you got to be very
careful because you lose credibility
with the people in the middle that are
somewhat reasonable well what you're
basically saying is like okay on the
surface it's ridiculous like the hitler
comments yeah the dictator comments but
then when you actually unpack it and
really start throwing definitions out
there and being like okay what is
actually freedom it's like well like
gerardo he says free state of florida
love it free state of florida and then
it just compels your argument even
further right i mean what kind of
dictator tells parents you get to choose
if your kid wears a mask or gets a
vaccine or not whereas in other states
the governor mandates one way like that
has to be done with no exceptions or
like they let local governments mandate
it and governor desantis just said no
everyone gets to assess their own risk
make the right decisions for their kids
everyone is different you know and
that's the opposite of what a real
dictator would do so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]